it's just after 1500 GMT and we start in
Somalia where there's been a suspected
suicide attack in the capital of
Mogadishu police and state media say
there have been a number of deaths two
car bombs exploded at a busy
intersection near several government
offices on Saturday afternoon the first
blast sending a plume of smoke over the
city several minutes later there was a
second explosion as ambulances arrived
on the scene let's bring in hodan Ali
and magadishu she's a senior advisor to
the city's mayor hadam thanks for being
with us what do the timing and location
of the attack tell us
well thank you for having me it's an
unfortunate uh time to be with you
um the location was really at the heart
of the show
um a symbolic place called zorbet the
minister of Education was the target
with the uh the twin bombings
um really you know a busy time uh
heavily used intersection but again
um you know al-shabab is is using all
its tactics to scare and make somalis in
the capital
so there has been an increase in attacks
against Somalian institutions recently
why do you think that is
declared all a war on Shabbat and there
has been an uprising against across the
country
um particularly in the Iran region and
the uh you know the South Central area
and that really has
um has been gaining momentum and has
been successful in large swath of land
across uh the South Central Somalia so
really this is sort of a last-ditch
effort from shawap to uh to make it
known to somalis how Savage they are and
how brutal they are by attacking
um average citizens who are going about
their day
is it possible for the government to
prevent these attacks because government
buildings institutional targets are
already heavily protected and still
these attacks are occurring
I mean obviously uh some of the areas
are soft targets just because
um it's used by the public it is they're
located in in large areas that are
um you know part of the city central so
it's really hard to sometimes prevent
these attacks but nevertheless I think
we have seen a reduction in in attacks
um the last attack was uh the hotel
hayat where you know the hotel was under
attack for nearly 48 Hours it just tells
you that shabab is
um being rooted out but they are really
a force to be reckoned with and it will
take time for Shabbat to be eliminated
from the capital but the work is ongoing
um now we'll see more attacks I am sure
just because
um of the ongoing government and and
Community Uprising that we are seeing
across the country all right hold on Ali
joining us from mogadishi today thank
you very much for your time